Yo estaba terminando de jugar
al fútbol con amigos
y mi esposa me avisa que rompió bolsa.
En ese momento estábamos esperando
nuestro quinto hijo,
pero este venía distinto,
porque pesaba poquito.
Estaba de solo seis meses y nacía ya.
Así que volamos al hospital
con miles de cosas en la cabeza
por todo lo que podía pasar,
y después de dos días bravos
nació Juan Bautista,
con apenas 800 gramos: un pecitito.
En ese momento, se imaginarán...
mezcla de alegría y de miedo.
Prematuro, incubadora,
lleno de enfermeras y médicos,
y mi familia a full,
porque había cuatro afuera,
y nadie te daba garantías de nada
porque, claro, era muy chiquito.
En ese momento no sabés
cómo va a seguir todo.
Lo que sí sabíamos era que íbamos
a estar muy acompañados,
y que a él no le iba a faltar nada:
iba a estar cuidado en cada detalle.
Y así fue: hoy tiene casi cuatro años
y tira abajo las paredes
de mi casa con sus pelotazos.
Creo que todos sabemos
lo que necesita un recién nacido,
pero creo que casi nadie sabe
lo que necesita alguien
que está en la otra punta de la vida.
Alguien que se está por morir.
Y de eso les vengo a hablar hoy.
Tengo el privilegio de trabajar
desde hace 15 años como médico,
acompañando a los que están en el final
de su vida con una enfermedad terminal.
Esto se llama cuidados paliativos,
y es el trabajo de un equipo para cuidar
como cualquiera de nosotros querría
y merecería ser cuidado
en un momento como ese.
Y cuando les hablo de personas
con una enfermedad terminal
no se imaginen viejitos nada más,
porque esto lamentablemente toca
a todas las edades de la vida:
laburantes, recién casados,
adolescentes, deportistas,
si estás haciendo la dieta de las harinas,
fumadores, no fumadores...
Esto de alguna u otra manera
nos roza a todos, y yo estoy seguro
que todos conocemos a alguien
que está luchando
contra una enfermedad como esta.
Se me vienen a la cabeza personas
que ahora estoy acompañando,
gente que quizá ustedes conocen,
gente que quizá está acá sentada,
o del otro lado, escuchándonos.
Y en honor a cada uno de ellos,
hoy quiero y debo decirles
que es muy probable que mucha de esa gente
esté sufriendo injustificadamente.
Porque en nuestras sociedades
solo una de cada diez personas
recibe el cuidado que corresponde
para semejante momento.
Y esto es gravísimo.
Significa, por ejemplo,
que allá afuera hay gente con dolor.
Pero no de esos dolores
de "Me torcí un tobillo",
"Me duele la cabeza"; pasajeros.
Dolores de esos que no te dejan dormir,
dolor que no te deja pensar.
Significa que hay gente
con gran incertidumbre porque no sabe
cómo va su tratamiento,
cómo sigue su enfermedad,
y ven que se van poniendo flacos,
que ya no pueden ir a trabajar,
y nadie les explica lo que está pasando.
Incertidumbre que a veces te aguijonea
más que cualquier otro síntoma.
Hay gente que obviamente siente cosas:
está ansiosa, angustiada,
tiene miedo, tiene dudas,
y necesita ser escuchada...
Y son poco escuchados.
Porque escuchar lleva tiempo.
Y hay gente que está yirando
por el sistema,
y ojalá nunca les pase esto,
rebotando en las guardias:
pidiendo ayuda en una guardia,
y yendo a otra porque acá no lo ayudan,
y llegan como sintiendo que molestan,
y de vuelta a casa,
y nadie los quiere internar,
porque son pacientes
que le generan gastos al sistema.
Y entonces quedan fuera del sistema.
Yo creo que esto, entre otras cosas pasa,
porque nos cuesta
hablar de la muerte.
Es un tema que nos da miedo.
Nos paraliza lo desconocido,
cómo será no estar más.
Y vemos películas,
con terapias intensivas, cables, tubos...
Miedo al deterioro físico:
esto de la chata, el papagayo,
depender de otros.
El otro día, una señora me decía:
"Matías, yo ya sé lo que tengo,
pero en un momento sentí
que el cuerpo se me puso como viejo,
y tengo solo 52 años.
Entonces, la consecuencia nefasta
de todo esto es que hoy hay gente
falleciendo anónimamente, sin despedirse,
sin organizarse, a veces sin saberlo.
Es un tema complicado,
no es un tema cómodo
para andar haciendo sociales,
no es un tema sexy
como dice un amigo, Juan.
Y esto es una parte importante
del problema.
La primera vez que fui a comer
a lo de mis suegros,
siempre me acuerdo
- esa noche nos conocíamos-,
en plena cena me tira:
"Bueno, a vos que trabajás
en esto de cuidados paliativos,
muchos regalos para el día
del médico no te deben hacer".
¿Y ustedes saben a quiénes
les cuesta más hablar de la muerte?
A los médicos.
Somos un poco cómplices
de mantener una falsa expectativa.
Hemos recibido este mandato de curar,
entonces te cuesta reconocer
cuando ya no podés resolver,
entonces agregás
tratamientos innecesarios,
diluís las respuestas,
y "de esto no se habla",
y va pasando el tiempo:
un tiempo que, en la vida
de esa gente, es precioso.
Un tiempo que es único.
Así como cuando te recibiste,
te casaste, nació tu hijo;
momentos de encuentros, momentos clave...
bueno, éste es el momento
en el que se cierra tu vida.
El último, y hay que darle
el lugar que se merece.
Vieron como esa última tarde
de verano en la playa.
El mar está helado y hay un viento cruzado
que levanta la sombrilla
pero vos decís, "Me meto, andá a saber
cuándo vuelvo a tocar el mar".
Bueno, acá pasa un poco lo mismo:
es un tiempo para aprovechar,
para mirar de frente.
No hay que quitarle a nadie la posibilidad
de que viva el final de su vida.
De que protagonice sus días,
tome sus decisiones,
de que nadie decida por él
dónde y con quién quiere estar.
De que disfrute con su gente,
sin dolor, sin síntomas.
De que pueda organizarse,
dejar sus legados.
De que pueda acomodar su alma.
De que sea quien escriba el final
de su propia biografía.
Y esto, que suena medio novelesco,
es un derecho que todos tenemos:
a vivir dignamente hasta el final,
tengas la enfermedad que tengas.
(Aplausos)
A ser cuidados
como ese bebé recién nacido.
Y está bueno saberlo
porque tenemos que exigirlo.
Los cuidados paliativos existen
desde hace muchos años.
Tenemos excelentes equipos
que están en los principales hospitales
de las grandes ciudades, en las prepagas,
que todavía no son muy conocidos.
Cada vez hay más.
Y los que menos saben de esto
y, por lo tanto, más lo padecen,
son los que menos tienen.
Por eso allá por el 2009,
con un grupo de amigos
nos propusimos generar algo distinto,
que llegue más y mejor a la gente
y fundamos el Hospice Buen Samaritano:
una casa para alojar
a personas sin recursos
y con una enfermedad terminal,
en donde un equipo de voluntarios,
además de médicos, enfermeras, psicólogos,
nos hacemos familia de esa gente
que está al costado de la vida,
y los recibimos,
más que como pacientes, como huéspedes,
que encuentran en la cabecera
de su cama su nombre:
Leo, Liliana, Ángel, José.
Llegan de la nada, agotadísimos,
desconfiados, doloridos
y les aseguro que acá empieza
a cambiar la película.
Porque les preguntás quiénes son,
les aliviás esos dolores que traen
hace meses inexplicablemente,
les contás algo de lo que está pasando,
y se dan cuenta de que hay gente
que los va a ayudar,
que los quiere cuidar,
que se quiere comprometer realmente,
que va a estar con ellos siempre.
Y entonces, ¿qué pasa?
Recuperan las ganas de comer,
vuelven a dormir una siesta,
redescubren que Dios está con ellos
en ese momento más que nunca,
y vuelven a rezar,
y recuperan la esperanza,
y dejan de ser un diagnóstico
para volver a sentirse personas.
(Aplausos)
Y nos dimos cuenta de que esto
no necesita ni de grandes gastos,
ni de grandes tecnologías,
ni de grandes instalaciones.
Necesita gente que se ponga en juego.
Entonces salimos de nuestra casa,
empezamos a ofrecerlo
en hospitales públicos, en municipios,
a donde no solamente llevamos
atención y medicación sino también cursos,
para que todo el mundo sepa
de qué se trata todo esto.
Y lo que está pasando es muy bueno.
Miles de personas están siendo acompañadas
en esa etapa especial de la vida.
Cientos de voluntarios
están dando su tiempo
para ponerse en juego ahí.
Equipos enteros de médicas, enfermeras,
psicólogos, trabajadores sociales,
están empezando a entender
y son capacidad instalada en esos lugares.
Y lo mejor: todos nos dimos cuenta
de que ya nadie tiene por qué sufrir.
Que esa famosa frase:
"Ya no hay nada más para hacer",
es una de las grandes trampas
de la medicina.
Porque cuando vos ofrecés
un cuidado, un acompañamiento,
un alivio de los síntomas,
profesional y humanizado,
la vida de la gente, de esta gente,
aunque se estén yendo, se transforma.
Y entonces nos encontramos con familias
que se reencuentran en ese momento
y que hablan naturalmente
sobre lo que está pasando
y se van preparando;
hijos que pasan tardes enteras
con sus padres, y comparten y disfrutan;
mamás que hacen
sus últimas tareas con sus hijos
y son capaces de dejar
sus últimos consejos...
Gente que te agradece:
esto es impresionante.
El otro día, en el [Hospice],
una mujer me decía:
"Matías, yo nunca me imaginé
que le iba a decir
de nuevo 'Papá' a mi viejo".
Por esas cosas de la vida,
se habían separado 15 años atrás
y se estaban volviendo a rencontrar
en esta semana tan especial.
Tan especial para ellos y para esos nietos
que conocieron a su abuelo,
y para nosotros que fuimos
parte de ese momento.
Entonces la verdad es que yo debo decirles
que no hemos acompañado curaciones,
pero sí profundas sanaciones,
personales y familiares,
en esa etapa de la vida
y esto es poderoso.
Cada año que pasa,
me convence un poquito más
que esto no depende de médicos,
de hospitales, de enfermeros.
Si cada uno de nosotros nos animamos
un poco más a hablar de estos temas,
si pedimos la ayuda adecuada
cuando la necesitamos,
acá hay una gran oportunidad
para que mucha gente viva mejor,
para que muchas familias estén mejor,
para que tengamos una sociedad mejor.
Siempre me preguntan,
"Vos que tenés cinco pibes
y que tu casa es un jardín de infantes,
y que tenés este trabajo
que es tan particular,
¿qué significa para vos terminar
bien un día de trabajo?,
¿con qué sensación
te quedás al final del día?"
Y lo que siento se parece un poco
a lo que me pasa
cuando me acerco a sus camas
en esos últimos días de la vida.
Como en el caso de Viviana,
esta joven mujer de 44 años,
que nos conocemos ya hace varios meses,
y que ahora está dormida,
con una respiración superficial,
(Imita respiración entrecortada)
con algunas pausas, pero tranquila,
con su marido al lado, como siempre.
Lo saludo con la mirada.
Los dos sabemos que falta poco.
Apenas está con un suerito,
con un poco de morfina,
para no tener dolor ni falta de aire.
La foto de sus tres varoncitos,
la luz de sus ojos.
Y me acerco un poco más,
y le tomo la mano,
y en ese momento, como un rayo
rememoro todo lo que compartimos,
lo que charlamos, su sonrisa,
su mirada, sus deseos, su carácter.
Qué gran mujer.
Me emociona pensar en ella.
Y le tomo el pulso, que apenas se siente,
y pasan unos minutos, largos,
y ya no tiene pulso.
Y dejó de respirar.
Recién estaba acá,
y ahora ya no está.
Misterioso segundo en el que siento
que el Cielo y la Tierra se tocan,
mientras ella se va,
serenamente, en paz.
(Aplausos)